[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au soit
pas trop vous n'avez rien au trot du une
en ours bizarre je descend vite chez
nicolas et pimprenelle
mon échelle il se passe des choses
curieuses
des robes de
[Musique]
soirée au fond qu'est-ce que je
change
mais
[Musique]
ce petit coquin que ce doute rappelé à
lui
[Musique]
l'homme
yahoo vient petit noeud
[Musique]
n'ont pas pu l'attraper il est sûr
montrent la cuisine une
rolls il est dans la salle de bain nu
[Musique]
bon il est dans la cuisse au long mines
là où l'ours je n'ai jamais entendu dire
miaou nounours arracha au mais qu'aucun
vous croyez me faire une farce vous
allez voir là où nicolas yahoo patronne
elle au
[Rires]
gouvernement celle ci contre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pauvre nounours il s'est encore laissé
avoir au patro le coquin ils m'ont
encore fait des blagues et moi je les ai
cru elle n'était pas bien et chante
nounours non mais je marchais ils se
sont moqués de moi mais ils ne m'auront
plus parole de nounours allant en route
mon bon nounours bonne nuit les enfants
feu deux pour un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en vo
bon
[Applaudissements]